[Music]
welcome thank you we're in
California follow next to Stanford we've
been watching you different people share
your a story from the shetel 13 the Navy
Seals I believe you spent several years
in the unit five years five years in the
unit as a combat Soldier uh we're in the
midst of a war uh you know we're in the
end of October and pretty much the whole
nation is coming together to work on
this and the impact you're doing here
already is is remarkable there's what's
happening know on the ground and this is
a global war and I think that the the
the work that you're doing here the
people you're meeting the stories you're
telling and the inspiration that you're
providing
is remarkable I got to see it from the
side it's kind of tough to be from far
I'm with my friends over there but uh
I'm trying to impact my way ref here
this work because I think that like I
really it's really important to support
now I see I never think thought like
it's so important to support people from
Far all around the world and either
because when you're in the Army like you
just focusing your team in like your
mission and right now I see like how
important is
it all the money and the
support the social supports
everything so I see it like it's uh one
of my goals to stay here and try to F I
love it tell me about the unity so we
know that this is a global war we see
everybody coming together United but
there's something about your unit
there's something about your personal
and particular experience in the fella
13 that really speaks to this whole idea
of of unity and working together tell me
a little bit about that more
generally so usually our
unit specific like missions that we get
like in normal time we say it's uh
special
missions also Wars are missions it's
like to
do special missions it's me like the
special Mission that's for example do a
small things that big unit cannot do and
like a small surgery so small things big
impact yeah Small Things big impact it's
important things and that's what it
that's what it sounds like from from the
stories it is there are things that I
can't tell but have to yeah but this is
our mission like in the war to do like
small thing to big
impact and Al also like in the
noral tell me a little bit strategically
in the war what does it mean that
there's small things that can be game
changers I want to really understand
this point because when most people
think about war they think about huge
Army against huge Army gunfire in the
middle of the battlefield or airplanes
up in the sky that's not always the case
with what you do and
yeah and the things you do are the game
changer sort of the 10x if I equated it
to the startup world tell me a little
bit about what you know how that
works first of all all the soldiers also
the unit are very very professional
because they
trained must Le one year and eight
months training of TR just training what
what do that include give me a little
bit of picture wow and you start like
for example we do simple example 60 guys
in a group after like tough test they
did
before and this start like in it's
called and it's five months it's like a
basic training that all the arms
doing after that we're
goinging start the real
things like three separated parts
each part like
training something
else all these
parts is it all individual or is there
also grouping because I remember hearing
that there's a lot of team building and
you really come out as a as a as a
really yeah you're really building your
team and also in this
time and there are like a lot of tests
each one there sometime they pi are or
just decide to go home because it's not
for them or it's too tough or whatever
and sometimes like they tell you to go
on you're not doing that so it's like
kind of a t time and it
show really each guy they choose like if
he can stay or not and depend on like
your skills your team skills
your your social teams your sport your
mental everything
and that's the way like they build a
team sometimes after you finish the
train you separate to another team and
you train over there like it's never
ended yeah you always keep learn things
what is this team idea tell me about the
team you have a team yeah what is it
what does it mean to be part of a team
as a part of
in first of all it's means a lot of
supports I see the smile
because a team it's like second family
for
me and first of all it's a family and
then it's a team
fors and special
together I I I really like I don't have
specific word to say about it because my
team it's like my family it's like my
people party special missions fights
everything how do you describe the trust
that you trust each other with your life
something I think the reason
that trust to each other it's the reason
that we pass really tough things
together and once you pass tough and
happy think if someone doesn't matter if
it's in the army or in the regular
life you you feel more connection more
trust between the people you know and
also
in
our like one of
the one of the strong things it's the
honest and to talk about things for
example every when we finish our day
every night so we're doing like a circle
and each one like talking our's day in a
really straight not like a not like a
pych like
a uh Circle but it's more like I was my
day like if you do bad things or you
want to talk to someone and really talk
to someone you said like sorry about
that on that or you clear things yeah
you clear things you don't I don't I
don't think that the average person
outside of the idea would expect the
fill 13 to sit down at the end of every
day and sort of do a pely circle is that
just a phly circle also like uh it's
also tough because sometimes your
officer can't and say like tough things
to you or whatever to all team
it's it's really it's going be tough
It's can be Happ be everything but it's
uh that's the way to get better every
day because you finish your day you look
back you see what he did what good what
I
didn't not good and like talk about it
like all the team or the officer told
you what what you can do good or not
and you're going to sleep like to the
next day how demanding is
it what how
demanding how difficult is
it
uh well sometimes like people ask me
like wow probably it's sof probably it's
like unbelivable like how we do that but
I I feel like it's just snow it's like
you have your friends you have your your
goals like to finish things so you're
just like you're just doing it you're
not thinking like if it's possible or
not how important is the for Israel for
the safety of isra people so think first
of all sh it's one of
the strong symbol for the country like
there are feeling that there's someone
behind you there are some unit that
super strong and they can do amazing
things I think our especially in our
unit it's to doing the things
that you cannot imagine or think it's
possible to do our job is to take a
mission a
mission that people say like we cannot
do it like or it's not possible to take
it see like smart people
or people with experience of everyone
and try to figure out that I can do it I
can make it
out and and then do it and do it then
Su and we don't hear about that success
which is a good thing because sometimes
yes sometimes no but yeah now I think
that there's this combination of of
intelligence experience resilience team
building execution that really brings
everything together you sort of have all
the units of the Army in one one team
and all of you exhibit all of the
qualities that make up a Commando team
to be able to go and execute on very use
of the word surgery before
yeah normally we have like also we have
like normal misss protect our
border and to stand there like to show
like the
strong specific
points because it's supporting also to
the enemy to see it
and it's important for us to do it yeah
and also like you said like it's a group
of people that's it's mix
of I said that why is it
important that the war that's taking
place in Israel is not only in Israel
why do we need the support of people
around the
why is it why is that
important in your eyes as a fighter as a
person who protects his country why is
it important that people here in
California around the world understand
what's happening you know we were at
Stanford yesterday we saw pictures of
our kidnapped brothers and sisters on
the ground stomped on sometimes yeah I
said that that touch to that's touch you
yeah uh first of all that are a huge
impact when you're a
soldier and you have that 10 minutes to
open your phone and see like uh videos
or whatever from all around the world
like
uh of people that talking to you or like
send money like you feel like you're not
alone you like you're not just fighting
for your country you fight like for
something like more biger something like
for all the
Jewish all around the world you
feel feel like it's more biger than you
what is what is this war for you I know
you serve for several years you you have
you have brothers in the Army as well
you just said that the war is not just
about the specific words for Jewish
people around the world talk a little
bit more on that
because so I
think when I served it's was a different
completely different from this war
because this
war it's more hurt hurt and more like
huge this thing has never happened to us
since the
hust right now the support all around
the world and all the Jewish people came
together like doesn't matter where you
live from where from your religion
you're not religion what it's your color
whatever doesn't matter everyone became
together and
one target just support Israel support
like our our army our
civilians and win home our home and
trying to just bring back the save
feeling
Israel that we are the Jewish not we're
not going anywhere MH
and once I see it here from California
and I see like so many Jewish people
here like how they supports
Israel
and I they really like it's something
very important doesn't matter like if
they there are people that I saw like
they never been in Israel they never
know even don't know what what is mean
Army and they feel like
so so like with with us like
so uh like they have a mission to do
something like everyone call me like
what I can do what I can do like they
they never been in Israel and they ask
me that why they can do and this really
warmed my heart and I can't explain like
the words what it's doing to the
soldier over there in
Israel like I said like you have the
time minutes you open your phone you see
all these
supports and you're understanding that
you're not alone and this is super
important not just for the soldier also
civilians other people that are back
home
shelters and people that
get from every
day
Rockets So I love how you're saying it's
not just about the the impact that
people here make is not just about the
resources it's first their the the fact
that they're uned with us in Israel yeah
it's this Con this concept of this Unity
We Are One People we're fighting for the
same cause we're fighting for our home
for Israel the Jewish Nation Jewish
Nation yeah that we never had until 75
years ago right and is being attacked
now uh but more than that it's for
Jewish people around the world yeah it
is
is and uh I think one of the beautiful
things
like my unit it's my friends in my team
they came back I got friends that they
came back from uh usually after you
finish your service so you're going to
travel which one like you're going to
Asia I been in South
America and I love of my friends came
back they stopped their travel and they
came back to
Israel and one of
the one of the problems was like they
didn't take enough equitment because a
lot of uh a lot of people just came back
to down everyone wanted to volunteer and
try to open in this War I think like we
have like uh
200% volunteer people 200% yeah yeah
it's like double incredible is but no
equipment
or and I think like I saw beautiful like
I saw like a beautiful private people
that send equipment from the US with
like get buy here and send like get land
with all like everyone was like crazy
but right now I think what are we trying
to do is like to do something more
bigger more
organized and trying to figure out like
how we can do it like more big and like
uh
give it to the soldier like my
unit in an organized
way and so you're here here in in
Silicon Valley Stanford San Diego Paulo
Alto meeting with different personas
that some of them are not even the
traditional supporters that that donate
money some of them are you know from
Tech some of them are from Academia some
of them are also ex Army and working
with your with your unit on identifying
the right gear that's needed and
obviously I know that a lot of it is a
lot of it is confidential and and you
can't necessarily share the intricate
details yeah but but you're really
bringing together this part of the world
which is perhaps one of the most
important parts of the world for the
Jewish people in Israel and and engaging
them with the with the with the fight
the fight for our country
yeah it is and I feel like right now
it's my fight to be here because I
[Music]
really it's really tough to me to be
here imagine
and it's like I swear to miss like what
happening over there but I feel like
this is my mission here try that because
understanding what is the that I from
here if you don't do it then who will I
don't know but there are a lot of good
people yeah but I'm trying to help
specific to my unit so
you're sort of an ambassador of your
unit yeah and it's not just your it's
your team but it's bigger than your team
it's bigger than my team and not just
for my team there's people that you love
that the unit who are
they wow my Three Brothers Three
Brothers yeah and so many friends so
many that's very special right I don't
want to gloss over that your four
brothers and Sh
yeah they all this one started and we
just like all of us
just it's became T dream to everyone not
which one in his way but yeah it's not
normal it's not normal
and and I
think it's not normal but it's super
normal for us it's like feel like a
family it's my second it's like
literally my second family because my
family is also over there
so yeah but it's it's normal but it's
not normal I don't know it's special for
people like to see it from outside but
for me it's like kind of Norm more
but yeah think also beautiful
that our unit is like uh Vibes like
doesn't matter like if like brother or
not the vies like
family so
and that's why it doesn't feel
like not feel like a away from me
because it's my family in home it's my
family over there it's the
same what is the biggest support that
people from here right now can support
you and your
unit and I'm putting inside the the the
fact that they're that they're with us
in mentality and they're supporting us
and they're and that's that's important
what tactical work do you see is needing
to get done now that would make an
impact on on the sh 13 on the Navy Seals
in as
well I think specific to our
unit it's just a lot of we have a lot of
missing equipment missing but we need to
BU to the
differences and
and I think it's the S the money it's
the like the supports thing that can
have right now
and I'm not talking about like General
support like uh post social and like
streets it's a different
thing if I'm talking like specific T
units it's money and you buy equipment
and such things that will make
it make different all different social
like LGE right to do that more and this
is not it's not General donation to
you're you're not you're not bringing in
general donations to or to large
organizations that support the general
idea you're supporting specific tactical
gear yeah that goes into gamechanging
missions this is not just to help the
soldiers in their day-to-day this is
equipment that can prend entally change
the course of how the war is being
played out yeah because like I said like
our mission they like specific and if
that soldier in the edge like have
more night vision equipment and more
good or
more let's say like at 10 levels from
what we have right now it will make a
difference and
to be honest I feel like I feel
uh bad and like like I think my unit
like have a b ego that's we're fine and
we have everything and don't worry and
we are here for you and like it's kind
of tough also for me to talk about it
I'm sure like we need help and
everything but I think in a worst
situation this
moment it's
like it doesn't matter it just like it's
leadership what what are you talking
about now you're putting inside
everything you're putting inside
everything your ego you're like thinking
that you have everything know the best
and making what you miss what you need
and trying to make it like the best way
I want to say it's been inspiring for me
to hear about your your work both in the
Army the work of your brothers who are
now literally now in combat and the
support that you bringing from here the
the people that that I got to experience
in now interacting with and and working
with truly being an ambassador of the
sh in one of the most important areas of
the world for the support of Jewish and
Israeli people I think people forget a
little bit how critical it is that that
in in these times it's not just
internally in Israel this place here
Silicon Valley Palo Alto San Diego Los
Angeles this is this place is a part of
the war and it's both for the for the
Jewish home but also a global fight on
terrorism and and as far as I see it
your team and the other teams in the sh
your ambassadors of the of the world of
the democratic world of fighting a fight
against terrorism both to defend my
family but also to defend really the the
safeguarding of you know the of society
and and what does it mean to live in a
peaceful world and I think that's
incredible and people need to really
understand
that understand I think people
understand I
agree I agree I super agree like we feel
like here is the center of the world
things are going all the biggest things
are coming out from here also this is
place also can change in
sports this big idea
against so I just want to say that
Israel is very lucky to have you here
and we don't have enough that can really
speak genuinely ego free about their
experience and about the importance of
what they're doing and um and and I just
want to thank you for this amazing
contribution
[Laughter]
[Music]